today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
the voter intimidation is starting my
friends today's example is actually an
in-uniform police officer doing it this
took place in miami florida a police
officer
in uniform with a trump mask that says
trump no more bs walking around a
polling place
the officer is daniel ubeda
wearing a trump 2020 mask inside
a polling place at miami's government
center
attorney steve simonides who is also
chairman of the miami-dade democratic
party says quote
he may have been going to vote but he
was in full uniform
with the mask and a gun that's
voter intimidation and indeed it is
illegal
in the state of florida florida's 2020
statutes 104.32
referring to political activities of
state county and municipal officers and
employees
says that no officer of the state or
any county or municipality can use their
authority
to influence an election or to influence
a vote period
and importantly that quote no employees
of the state
can participate in any political
campaign while on duty
if you violate it it's actually a
misdemeanor in the first
degree miami police immediately alerted
to it by people who saw this they
tweeted about it saying quote
we are aware of the photograph being
circulated of a miami police officer
wearing a political mask
in uniform this behavior is unacceptable
a violation of department policy and is
being addressed
immediately now of course there's a
bigger issue
this is an officer who broke the law he
shouldn't be working in law enforcement
period but we have no national database
of bad actor police officers we have no
such requirements we likely won't
anytime soon as i mentioned
months ago when the george floyd protest
started in the context of the police
reforms i would like to see
a national bad actors database something
that would be brutally
fought to the death by police unions and
more than likely
we will get a sort of meaningless slap
on the wrist coming for this officer
don't worry he won't do it again at
least not for
four more years big consequences and in
all seriousness someone sworn to uphold
the law
breaking the law while in uniform
a police department is as good as its
worst
officer and this is an individual daniel
ubeda
who may end up with a couple of weeks of
paid administrative leave while they
investigate what happened does anybody
think that's going to teach this guy a
lesson
but as i've said before keep me posted
on this stuff if you come across it i
got an email yesterday
i don't want to say too much because i
want to look at it myself but i got an
email yesterday
not about intimidation well actually it
sort of is
it's intimidation by text message okay
i'm asking for more information and i'm
going back and forth with the viewer to
really
vet the story but i may have that for
you tomorrow or the next day but if you
see
intimidation uh if you get intimidatory
emails if you see intimidation at
polling places
let me know video is of course
ideal if you can safely and legally
record it if you can't
let me know what happened but the
reports are starting to come in and i
can only imagine
because listen they've said right trump
said
go and monitor polling places they've
said
we are going to try to have
law enforcement of possibly federal
military at polling places
they've mentioned everything in passing
at some point and who knows what
they're actually going to try to do so
help help me
get the word out if indeed you are
seeing that hey speaking of
protests there's a very important report
from the associated press
which looked at the arrests that took
place at and related to the various
protests that we've seen around the
country over the last several months
and the study found that most of the
people arrested at the protests
are not leftist radicals are not
affiliated with antifa to the extent
that one can be affiliated with antifa
they are not
anarchists or anarchists as donald trump
sometimes says
the way that trump and his cronies and
many republicans
have been portraying the small
minority of individuals at protests
i don't call them protesters because the
ones that are arrested they're not
protesting they're doing other things
but let's reset a little bit before we
get into the data
since the george floyd and anti-police
brutality protests that we've seen
the trumpian republican line has been
dangerous violent leftist socialist
communist marxist anarchists or some
combination thereof
are wreaking havoc destroying things
burning things down the left is violent
and this is the future of joe biden's
america even though it's donald trump's
america right now
now all along we knew the protests have
been mostly peaceful
and there have been provocateurs there
have been
rioters who are not protesters who
are provoking and rioting
and committing crimes and it is a very
very small number of people okay
the associated press looked at the
roughly 300 people arrested at the
various protests
and found that most of the people
arrested
even though the protests are happening
in cities are
suburban adults who came into the cities
where the protests took place
from the exact suburbs that donald trump
says he needs to protect
from the urban people which often is
code for non-white people but but
of course there are urban white people
and urban black people urban hispanic
people etc
understand that those are the people
coming
into the cities to create chaos uh
commit some crimes and getting
themselves arrested now of course
there are people who got arrested from
the nearly 300
whose political views if you were to sit
down with them and do an interview are
left-leaning political views
but there are plenty whose views are
right-wing there are plenty who are sort
of not political and just taking
advantage
of of a situation to provoke most have
no affiliation with any particular group
some have pre-existing criminal records
some don't
some were illegally carrying weapons at
the times of their arrests some were not
but certainly almost no you know this
idea of ties to antifa
almost non-existent most no previous
criminality period
the most common charges against those
arrested are number one arson
followed by illegal possession of a
firearm just
those two crimes are about 45
of all the arrests and then you've got
some of these vague
civil unrest disorderly conduct
impeding a federal officer some property
damage
some failing to obey a lawful order and
when you look at the list
lots of these are these sort of bs
charges
equivalent to resisting arrest and and
i'm certainly including disorderly
conduct in that
not obeying a lawful order you know that
that can be
a police officer says leave now
and you leave but too slowly and the
officer
too slowly in the opinion of the officer
and then the officer says you're not
obeying a lawful order
interfering with law enforcement the
these can be bs charges or they can be
legitimate
in all of these three 286
i believe uh charges the only court
documents that even
reference antifa our one case in boston
where there was suspected antifa
activity that was being investigated
that's certainly not definitive that's
the one reference and of course in the
midst of this
there are plenty of instances of
right-wing militia and far-right
extremists who have been arrested two
missouri militia members
three boogaloo movement members that's
another right-wing group and so on so we
have a report now an investigation which
tells us
what we already suspected but the right
either doesn't understand or won't
accept
the other obvious issue with saying a
person is part of antifa
as we've talked about before is that
antifa is not an organization it's more
an ideology
most mostly it's just benignly being
anti-fascist now even i
as someone who has said i'm against many
of the tactics that some operating under
the name
anti for the banner of antifa sometimes
use i am against fascism but i'm not
part of any organization
and there really is no organization
which is part of the double-edged sword
where
you can accuse anyone of being part of
an organization that isn't really an
organization it's like saying i'm a
member of white nationalism
as an example well okay that's really an
ideology
there are groups that are heavily white
nationalist in nature like the kkk
but being a a member of white
nationalism makes about as much sense as
being a member
of antifa the other really important
element to think about
is whether or not antifa is a group or
an
extremist group it's actually irrelevant
to the findings the people from the left
who are in the streets protesting
are generally not violent and unlike the
right
they've not been radicalized by some
monolithic
right-wing media apparatus or by trump
or by q anon
they're just normal people asking for
change and that is a totally separate
issue
from whether antifa is or isn't an
organization
almost everybody participating in these
protests has nothing to do whatsoever
with the ideology nor with the
with the organization so if you're
surprised let me know
i'm on twitter at deepakman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to dot
com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded by
memberships which you can grab at
joinpacman.com
we do have hatred mail for you this week
hatred mail really
escalating i guess i would say quick
reminder about what hatred mail is
to the over two hundred thousand
americans who died from covet 19.
you let it dominate your life didn't you
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
lots of people very very angry with me
for some reason in
in in advance of the election take a
listen to this one as it needs
very little introduction but it is the
this is an
uh a viewer is weighing in on the
supreme court nomination that's how i
would
introduce it if it was not the rantings
of a lunatic take a listen
soyboy cuckboy pacman fill the seat
winning winning winning trump forever
i'd put money up that pacman is either a
cuck
or gay can tell this guy likes to gossip
that's what i think of when i see soft
pale intellectuals who aren't actually
about america
or freedom and a jew to boot
the full package so you've got a
combination there
of uh gender stereotypes
about alpha and beta males anti-semitism
which is just a fixture of hatred mail
and it has been for years
really just like a mishmash of nonsense
now here's
this is a serious question i actually
want to hear from people on this
as opposed to many of the things i say i
don't really want to hear from you this
one i really do
what kind of a job do you think folks
who write emails like this have like
could this be an accountant that emailed
me about being a suck
a soy boy cuckboy is it possible that
this is a
a pediatric oncologist that wrote me
this like i'm not
i don't want to stereotype who would
write such an email
but what do you imagine would be the
day-to-day job
of somebody like that if they even have
a job i don't know the answer to that uh
what do you imagine let me know
and remember that you can use the coupon
code hatred 40
to get 40 off the membership of your
choice on my website joinpakman.com
here's the spelling and there's
confusion about the spelling it's h-a-t
like a hat
h-a-t-r-i-o-t hat riot like the two
words
h-a-t-r-i-o-t four-zero forty percent
off
the membership of your choice at
joinpakman.com
you can just tell from watching donald
trump's rallies this week that there's
something new going on there's a sort of
desperate anger i would call it that
wasn't really there before and it
culminated in humiliating fashion last
night
with donald trump at a rally in erie
pennsylvania which started nearly 50
minutes late for
no particular reason i covered part of
it live donald trump telling the
audience
he doesn't even want to be there but
he's losing now
and he sort of has to be there he
doesn't want to but he had to do it
great way to get the audience on your
side right take a look
because you know before the play came in
i had it made
i wasn't coming to erie i mean i have to
be honest there's no way i was coming
i didn't have to i would have called you
and said hey erie you know if you have a
chance get out
but we had this thing won we were so far
up we had the greatest economy ever
greatest jobs greatest everything
and then we got hit with the plague and
i had to go back to work hello erie
may i please have your vote i wouldn't
be here if i didn't have to
because i screwed up the coronavirus
response imagine if barack obama had
ever said that
imagine if joe biden said that during
this election or if hillary clinton had
said that back in 2016
i really don't want to be here but i had
to come here to this lame
place because i'm losing and by the way
if you don't vote for me i will never
come back which donald trump has been
saying
in pennsylvania and in north carolina
and in many other places and
by the way this idea that coronavirus
had to hurt him that inevitably the
virus hurt him so now he has to campaign
world leaders who did a good job with
the virus are cruising to re-election
jacinda ardern in new zealand
sailed to overwhelming re-elections and
a bigger labor majority than i think new
zealand has ever seen
because she handled the coronavirus
properly as i've said before if trump
had handled the virus properly
biden would have no shot right now so
that's also
completely wrong then maybe the most
humiliating moment of this rally
donald trump saying nobody wants him
really i can't believe it
you better give me the credit damn it
i'll tell you what i put
what i've gone through the drug
companies they're spending a fortune on
fake ads
they don't want me they don't want me
china doesn't want me
iran doesn't want me nobody wants me
nobody
[Music]
eerie eerie wants me it's easy to write
this stuff off as merely the rantings of
a madman
but i think there is something real here
which is donald trump does see the polls
and even though publicly he says he's
winning he knows he might lose
he does realize that everything he's
doing is sinking him further and further
he does the first debate the polls
collapse uh
uh he continues to crater in many
important states and i think trump is
cognizant of that and that's why you're
seeing
this attitude from from donald trump
trump then
still confused about how stealth planes
work
trump still seems to think that stealth
planes
are invisible to the naked eye rather
than invisible to enemy radar
terry we now have the greatest equipment
we've ever had
we are the envy of russia and china and
everybody in the world we have the best
missiles and rockets and tanks
and planes f35
stealth you can't see it other than that
it's not so great
you can't see it i went to one of the
pilots i said how good is this plane
well it's really good
why is it good because the enemy can't
see it i said i don't know too much
about what you do
sounds good to me continuing that uh old
trope
and then a bizarre moment when
republican congressman mike kelly says
no flu is going to keep trump down
again rehabilitating this false notion
that coronavirus is the flu
if this is the time this is your solemn
oath to america we're going to make
america great again
again because of donald j trump
there's no flu that's going to keep this
man down
he makes the energizer bunny look like a
deadhead
no flu keeping trump down but
950 americans
did die yesterday as we approach
spike number three of coronavirus
here's a completely incoherent thought
from donald trump
i can't even pretend to explain this one
to you
it's a verbal inkblot take a look you
have seen what's been going on how well
we're doing
did you see the recent poll just came
out
56 of the people want to be here
not four years ago they want to be with
us in
what we're calling we're rounding the
turn on the pandemic
56 and it's a record
epic job growth safe vaccines
that quickly end the pandemic it's
ending
normal life that's all we want you know
what we want
normal life
just not making any sense and then trump
i guess wrapping up sort of early
yesterday because
it was cold in erie pennsylvania trump
sounding sedated by the end listen to
the slow-motion version
of trump's now ubiquitous uh rally
closing
that i know you well a lot of time in
this
incredible land this beautiful place
this place of history
the incredible people of pennsylvania we
have
made america powerful again our military
never been like this remember at the
beginning when the
overrated general said to me sir we have
no ammunition
i said no president should ever have
that
no president should ever hear those
words sir we have no ammunition
we now have so much ammunition that even
mike would be impressed
wrapping up there with a sort of sedated
sounding nod
to the military industrial complex trump
tonight
in charlotte north carolina and then of
course tomorrow night
the second and what will be the final
presidential debate between joe biden
and donald trump i will be covering it
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me at about half
past 8 p.m eastern time
and of course continued coverage clips
polling memes and other hijinks
on the david pakman show instagram at
david pakman show
again uh uh if you want to see me voting
very
strongly uh voting over the weekend
catch video of me voting on my instagram
page
david pakman we'll take a quick break
our deep dive
into systemic racism coming up after the
break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
in the 1960s in the united states with
the passing of the civil rights act we
saw what many consider
to be sort of the official end of the
absolute
most explicit and formal types of
government
racism when we ended mandated
segregation
we outlawed many other types of racial
discrimination
but since then and really to this day
black and hispanic americans continue to
suffer from a variety
of social and economic inequities with
regard to wealth education
health outcomes cycles of crime and
incarceration the list is a mile long
when we're talking about socioeconomic
adversities that
disproportionately impact populations of
color
over the past 50 or 60 years in the time
since the civil rights movement we've
seen many racial equality movements try
to illuminate and put a spotlight on and
address these problems
and these movements tend to acknowledge
that these problems
are the ripple effects of historical
institutional racism like slavery and
jim crow
and these movements have pushed for
solutions that are designed to help
these groups in particular
as remedies for problems that impact
them
disproportionately this has taken the
form of
affirmative action scholarships for
minority students
bussing to integrate schools federal
financial support for historically black
colleges government
programs that help minority businesses
these are all forms of action
that solve or try to solve race-based
problems
in the united states over the past half
century
what we've also seen consistently in
parallel is pushback
against these racial equality
initiatives here are
a few clips of some popular
conservatives making comments
which i believe accurately sum up sum up
the prevailing right-wing narrative on
systemic racism with regard to
socioeconomics
one could certainly say during the jim
crow era when when
you know african-americans couldn't vote
that's systemic racism you have you have
things
in the system that are contributing to
racism
is systemic racism still a reality today
it is not about reality it is the
opposite of a reality it's a
an illusion if you can point to me to
the law or the practice that's in place
that makes that somehow keeps me out
if there's two people that that are
working the exact same and putting out
the same exerting the same amount of
effort and you're gonna tell me that as
a black person
i can't get ahead it doesn't exist there
are lots of rich black people in america
and there are lots of poor white people
in america yeah so what so
because black people in the united
states are disproportionately poorer
than white people in the united states
it's actually yeah it's ignoring the
real problem which is how do we get poor
people to be richer
systemic racism does not exist there are
no laws in america meaning the system
doesn't mean racism doesn't exist racism
exists there are people who are racist
and you should do everything you can to
show them that their ideas are wrong
and that you should not be judging
someone based on their race of course
but the idea that there is systemic
racism meaning that there are laws in
place that treat black people
differently or asian people differently
or white people differently
simply doesn't exist tree if you can get
an economy that's as free as possible
you will have
more and more people regardless of the
color of their skin being able to
partake in an economy
so those comments uh cover a bunch of
the
predominant views from the right on
systemic racism those were clips of
three of the most popular
right-wing online broadcasters so the
first thing i want to point out is
they are defining systemic racism so
narrowly
that it would only refer to racism by
the government
and only the most explicit and official
forms of government racism
like jim crow for example and that's how
they're able to say
that systemic racism doesn't exist if
someone's constantly asserting something
that everyone already accepts is true
such as slavery and jim crow no longer
exist
it's likely that they're either
accidentally or purposefully
misunderstanding what they are trying to
argue against
that's what's happening here i've never
encountered someone who asserts that
systemic racism is a problem today
while defining racism in such a narrow
way people usually use the term
systemic racism to denote any type of
racial biases formal
or informal by a system or someone
acting on behalf of a system
which could take the form of racial bias
by police officers or by
a law enforcement system racial bias
by people hiring at a company racial
bias in education like a standardized
test
that puts certain racial groups at a
disadvantage it doesn't even necessarily
have to be racism by an individual
importantly
it could just be a system doing
something that in practice
disadvantages members of a certain group
on the basis of their race and i think
that the
concept requiring a little bit of nuance
is exactly why
some people get confused some people get
defensive about the word racism being
involved so maybe we can have a separate
conversation about finding a better term
which is fine
but that's what people mean when they
say there is
active systemic racism present in the
year 2020.
so i think a lot of conservatives are
confused about the definition
if they act as though it's synonymous
only with slavery and jim crow
or some of them are straw manning in bad
faith
to avoid actually engaging with the
reality on the ground
but the conservatives i played in the
clips what they also
seem to be saying is that systemic
racism as someone like
me would define it doesn't exist their
sentiment is
slavery and jim crow are over black
people
no longer face any types of
disadvantages there are no systemic
biases against black people there are no
lingering effects from historical
institutional uh inequality unfairness
that still
leave the deck stacked against minority
individuals black and white people on
average have
identical opportunity to succeed they
would assert
the other thing they seem to be saying
is that
because they don't believe those racial
biases exist
we shouldn't be looking at minority
poverty
through the lens of race in order to
solve it
with racial social justice action
they say we should instead look at black
poverty for example
as an arbitrary piece of poverty as a
whole
and we should try to solve black poverty
merely by
fixing poverty as a whole and in
addition to saying
that racial solutions to for example
black or hispanic poverty are
unnecessary
often they will add that those racial
solutions dismiss
ignore or belittle white poverty and
they discount
the personal responsibility of
non-white individuals to improve their
own lives but it's not surprising that
that's the direction conservatives would
go
because each of those pieces fits
beautifully into
the conservative meta-narratives that
we've been following for example
racial inequality is generally overblown
identity politics is bad
government intervention is the wrong way
to fix anything capitalism and
meritocracy
ultimately are the answers to everything
what conservatives
like these are not realizing is that
there are social and economic problems
today in the united states that affect
minorities in specific ways black
folks as a group do have certain
types of particular disadvantages and to
admit that
is a reality doesn't mean that you're
deriding
the poverty of other races or in general
and it doesn't mean you're devaluing
anybody's individual responsibility
it doesn't mean that there aren't things
we can also be doing generally
to help everybody in a situation of
hardship regardless of race
of course we want to be thinking about
those solutions too and i talk about
those solutions every day
i might even agree with somebody like
ben shapiro when he says
that the mere existence of a black white
poverty gap
alone is not necessarily a justification
for using race
as the context to fix black poverty
the fact that black folks are
impoverished at a higher rate than white
people
by itself might not justify racial
solutions
as opposed to solutions that improve the
lives of all groups
but what these people on the right seem
never to recognize
is that certain opportunity gaps also
still exist
not only do black folks in many respects
have worse
outcomes on average black folks also
have diminished opportunity to improve
those outcomes compared
to white people on average on average
that's what these conservatives are
missing and it's the reason why it is
actually useful to explore
certain solutions that are tailored
towards certain particular racial
inequalities
in some ways black and white poverty can
be different there are many metrics
that illustrate gaps between a black
person and a white person
of the same income there was a
groundbreaking study
by stanford and harvard researchers from
2018 which combined census data on race
with irs tax returns
allowing them to compare the income of
parents with the income of their grown
children
over the span of 1989 to 2015
for the purpose of tracking
intergenerational mobility which is the
degree to which children
economically surpass their parents or
fall behind and what they found
is that downward mobility occurs at a
much higher rate among black americans
than among white americans
when you compare black and white people
with similar incomes this was true even
among the children of higher income
parents of both races
children of white parents in the top
fifth of the income distribution
have a 41 percent chance of staying at
that income level
children of black parents in that
highest income level
only have an 18 chance of staying at
that income level so regardless of how
much money your parents make
if you were black you are less likely to
achieve the economic status of your
parents or hire
sadly i can already imagine some people
are going to butt in with
oh well maybe it has something to do
with intelligence or single parenthood
or something like that
the study found that the black white
mobility gap
is entirely driven by black and white
males there was very little gap between
black and white
females which would rule out genetic
factors
between races as an explanation if
that's your sort of thing to look at
the study also looked at family
structure and it found
that the huge gap is there regardless of
whether children came from one or two
parent homes
which debunks the conservative idea that
lower marriage rates are responsible but
a factor
that does tend to powerfully predict
economic mobility
is the average income of the
neighborhood in which a child was raised
a study by harvard economists published
in 2015
showed overwhelming evidence for this
the researchers looked at 16 years of
tax records
to track pairs of children and parents
and they found that the affluence of a
child's
neighborhood is the single best
predictor of their long-term
upward mobility the amount of money in
an area where a child grows up
is strongly correlated with that child's
ability to achieve
more socioeconomic success than their
parents
a study was published in 2015 by the
american academy of political and social
science conducted by researchers
at stanford by looking at census data
which found that
among black and white families with
similar incomes
white families are much more likely to
live in neighborhoods
with higher average incomes and of
course this means
that the white family is more likely to
have access to better schools
better child care better parks better
transportation
options the list of advantages in a high
income neighborhood
relative to a low income neighborhood is
a very very long list
and between a black and white family of
similar income
the difference between the average
incomes of their neighborhoods is not
small
it's huge so to put all of this together
we have
the mobility gap between black and white
people of similar incomes
the mobility of anyone regardless of
race
tends to be predicted by the average
income of the neighborhood where they
grew up
and we see that a black family with the
same income as a white family
is more likely to live in a poorer
neighborhood
and that's because black people tend to
live near other black people
and black people have lower incomes than
white people
on average and of course that is what we
call racial housing segregation the
geographic
separation of races and it is a racial
issue so
we've demonstrated one of many examples
of a social problem
in 2020 which can be usefully analyzed
in terms of race and it warrants
racial justice action the problem is
that black folks have
less upward mobility than white folks
the cause of the problem
is racial housing segregation and the
solution
would be integrating housing to a
greater degree
there are so many other examples of
social problems today
that demand racial justice solutions in
education health care the justice system
i'd have nowhere near enough time in
this video to go
into each and every one of them so let's
flesh out
this example we're dealing with housing
segregation before we start talking
about solutions to segregation we should
contemplate
how the housing segregation that exists
today came to be
a lot of people think that people of the
same races
ended up living in the same areas
accidentally or as a result of personal
choice
but actually most of today's racial
segregation in every city across america
results from explicitly racist
government policies
throughout the late 19th and early 20th
century many american cities passed
zoning ordinances prohibiting black
people from moving onto a block
that was majority white starting in 1934
the federal government gave white people
better access to affordable mortgages
while designating black neighborhoods in
cities across america
as zones where banks should not offer
mortgages this was known as redlining
which encouraged white people
to move to homogenously white suburbs
and it trapped black people in decaying
neighborhoods
also in the 1930s the public works
administration
built tens of thousands of public
housing complexes all over the country
all of which had a designation for which
racial group was allowed to live there
and almost all of them were either all
white or all black and much of the
racial segregation
that it caused is still present today
there are plenty of other instances of
government mandating
racial housing segregation deliberate
codified
government racism is what gave us almost
all of the housing segregation we see
today and now
white people and black people are more
segregated from one another
then white people are segregated from
asian or hispanic people as examples
and more so than poor and non-poor
people are segregated from one another
and black white segregation puts a
hugely unfair
burden on black people it has much worse
effects for a black family living in a
black neighborhood
who have the same income and education
as a white family living
in a white neighborhood the average
middle class black family
lives in a neighborhood with a higher
poverty rate than the average
low income white person segregation also
prevents home values
from appreciating in black neighborhoods
because of white folks reluctance to buy
a home
in a black neighborhood even when all
other attributes of homes and
neighborhoods are equal
which by the way is an example of
systemic racism happening
actively in the year 2020 and it's a
type of systemic racism with a huge
impact on black wealth since someone's
home
is often their largest financial asset
so the crucial thing
here is that higher poverty rates in the
neighborhood
means lower quality resources for
everyone who lives there
segregation is the biggest barrier
between
black people and higher income wealth
better education health care employment
opportunities and so on
one might even be able to say that today
the government's refusal to integrate
housing more effectively
to fix the problems that government
created originally
could itself be another example of
ongoing systemic racism in 2020
the government not doing something is
just as much a policy decision
as the government doing something sure
someone like ben shapiro can sit back
and say
yeah okay whatever happened in the past
with racism and segregation was bad but
now that the government has stopped
actively mandating segregation we can
just wipe the slate clean we can just
blame individual black people for being
poor but that would be a complete
misunderstanding of the forces that
created these problems and the forces
that would be necessary to fix them
government has a ton of power obviously
and it used this power to segregate
for a long time that same amount of
power we would be required to
undo it this is where we get to the
distinction
between desegregation and integration
desegregation is when a government stops
separating people
integration is the process of
unseparating those same people which has
not happened
so we're currently stuck in a state of
segregation essentially in a way the
civil rights act did not accomplish as
much as conservatives seem to think it
did
it didn't hit the reset button on racial
inequality racial groups in the united
states are not
on a level playing field so what can
government do
to counteract segregation as a way to
give black people more economic
opportunity well
to start with we could reinstitute the
obama obama-era policy
of requiring localities that receive
federal money for housing
to identify and try to remedy housing
practices that promote racial bias
the policy that was suspended by the
trump administration which donald trump
completely blew out of proportion in
terms of what it did
and uh donald trump has made clear that
he has no interest in dealing with that
issue and in fact in his personal past
has a history of racial
housing discrimination commenting on his
elimination
of this anti-racist policy trump
actually tweeted i am happy to inform
all of the people living in their
suburban lifestyle dream
that you will no longer be bothered or
financially hurt
by having low-income housing built in
your neighborhood enjoy
that's another example of institutional
racism in 2020 if i've ever seen one
another step we could take to counter
segregation
by reducing housing discrimination is to
increase
the use of fair housing testers who are
individuals who pose
as potential buyers and renters to
gather information
on possible instances of illegal
racial housing discrimination because
this discrimination tends to push black
people
out of white areas tests like these have
been funded by the department of housing
and urban development
and they've uncovered a staggering
amount of racial discrimination for
example they did a test in chicago
in 2018 and identified racial
discrimination
27 of the time there's
some more current systemic racism as an
example for you nevertheless
hud does not fund these tests anywhere
near the level
that matches how pervasive and
destructive we've observed this problem
to be
we have to be better about enforcing
anti-housing discrimination laws that
are already on the books
government could also be bolstering
inclusionary zoning policies which
require home builders to make sure that
portions of new housing units are
affordable to low and moderate income
people
to eliminate the financial barriers that
often end up keeping poor black families
from finding an affordable home in a
good neighborhood
we could also be using more federal
housing subsidies to
help lower-income black families move
into better neighborhoods the low-income
housing
tax credit could be used to develop
subsidized rental housing
in non-poor neighborhoods there is great
new research
that it illustrates that what we have
been doing
with this has had huge payoffs
especially for the kids
of low-income families there are many
other strategies
we could be using to um
disperse black families so that lower
income households aren't so concentrated
new policies that can be implemented and
through better funding and enforcement
of initiatives that already exist
could be significantly beneficial but i
wanted to
explore just racial housing segregation
as an example
to illustrate some points about systemic
racism and how much can be done about it
it's a topic that is always relevant and
worthy of a deep dive
but especially right now with everything
going on with black lives matter the
discussions around race that are
happening
over the past few months while they've
had the country's attention
black folks in the u.s and allies
of all kinds have been trying to shed
light on a number of really
important problems in the country things
that this country
has to start dealing with it's way
overdue but i'm seeing some people
actually confused about what are even
the starting points for these
conversations
the reality is racism can take many
different forms some people just have an
overly simplistic
conception of what racism is people
start talking about
systemic racism conservatives respond
with i have no idea what you're talking
about we have no more
slavery jim crow is over we ended that a
long time ago
so racial injustice no longer exists
that perspective
misunderstands deliberately or
accidentally what systemic racism is and
it
ignores the fact that systemic racism
exists and is just another form of
racism we also have to refute
the common conservative notion that
black hardships
can only be productively discussed in
the context of
hardship or poverty in general instead
of acknowledging
additional racial components that are
often involved there are some issues
that
are more accurately understood when you
take into account
racial injustices that may be at play so
that you can solve them
with specially catered solutions
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so the bad news will just not stop
coming for donald trump a bombshell new
york times article this week yesterday
in fact revealing that donald trump has
an undisclosed
bank account in china and it exposes a
whole
series of chinese business pursuits this
is of course the same donald trump
that has been going after china for the
virus and going after china for doing
this and that unfair thing to the united
states the same donald trump that has
been repeating for months that if joe
biden were to be president
china would control biden the same trump
whose republican party
has been going after joe biden's son
hunter biden
for opening a bank account in china that
donald trump
has a bank account in china and a long
history of
trying to do business with china the new
york times has continued to analyze the
tax records that were the basis for the
blockbuster story
about trump paying no federal taxes in
10 of the last 15 years from a few weeks
ago
which feels like years ago by the way
that story was just a few weeks ago
and the new york times has now learned
that donald trump has bank accounts in
britain
in ireland and yes in china the chinese
bank account
shocker was not on donald trump's public
financial disclosures because it's held
under
a convenient corporate name and that
chinese bank account paid a hundred and
eighty eight thousand dollars in taxes
to the chinese government between 2013
and 2015.
understand that that means trump's
business
paid more tax to the chinese government
in those years
than trump paid in the united states
federally and donald trump
is saying biden has the china problem
and we know that trump projects all the
time
trump accuses others of being corrupt
when he's corrupt
trump accuses others of nepotism when
he's the king of nepotism
trump accuses others of receiving
softball interviews
when he gets weekly softball interviews
from fox and friends and sean hannity
and maria bartiromo and eric boling
yesterday and the whole cast at fox news
but this is another level of projection
with china
claiming for weeks now that hunter biden
has this and that financial connection
to china and it's a problem for
joe biden and so on and all along donald
trump has had an undisclosed chinese
bank account
and this puts a huge list of actions
related to china
under the microscope once again many
chinese government proposals
came after trump became president ivanka
trump
won chinese trademark approvals
for her was it clothing or handbags
uh after she joined the white house
staff
and on and on and on and all of these
now need to be scrutinized under a new
light not that they didn't need to be
scrutinized before
it's a perfect amalgam of possible
nepotism cronyism and corruption
which i don't think we will ever know
the full scope of i know there's this
idea
that after trump leaves whether it's in
in you know a few months or in four
years
there will be investigations and we'll
eventually get to the bottom of it i
don't think we will
and let me just give you one more
example and again
each one of these examples could be a
huge story
a major investigation by itself and i
assure you
if this was a story about chelsea
clinton during a hillary presidency
instead of about ivanka it would be a
huge story
this from the same new york times
investigation
says quote not long after winning the
2016 election mr trump reported selling
a penthouse
in one of his manhattan buildings for
15.8 million dollars
to a chinese-american businesswoman
named xiaoyan chen
who bought the unit previously occupied
by ivanka trump and her husband jared
kushner
in an off-market transaction ms chen
runs an international consulting firm
and reportedly has high level
connections to government and political
elites in china
circumstantially that is
as much of a red flag or more ripe for
investigation
than anything that we have about hunter
biden and joe biden right now
by itself that sale could be
a huge story to investigate but again we
may never know the full scope of what's
gone down
and what favors have been offered and
done in exchange for what
one of you emailed me about this story
saying what is the breaking point for
trump supporters and for republicans
with this stuff
republican congressmen all know trump
may be
tied to all of these different countries
and what's the breaking point the answer
is
we're 13 days away from the election
there is no breaking point if trump wins
they win in a sense and they just try to
maintain power if trump loses
they start to distance themselves from
trump pretend they never really
supported him he wasn't
really a republican and move on and you
could apply that prediction
not just to republican elected officials
but just your average run-of-the-mill
trump supporter and we will see
what the new york times has in the next
13 days based on these documents
so this next story started to develop
last night and i i have to tell you i
can't wait
i am really like a kid on christmas
morning and yeah i'm jewish but the
metaphor just works like a kid on
christmas morning
waiting for video to be released because
donald trump yesterday was interviewed
for an upcoming episode of 60 minutes
and we've learned
that in the middle of the interview
trump abruptly and furiously got up and
left
ending the interview with 60 minutes
correspondent leslie stahl
and then started tweeting ridiculous
things about the interview
you this has to be seen to be believed
the reporting
is that in the interview trump became
frustrated
with the questions that leslie stahl was
asking that tracks perfectly with
trump's displeasure
at being asked real questions and in
particular in situations where he can't
weasel his way out
the example from last week's town hall
where savannah guthrie
actually pressed trump about his obvious
lies as to
when was he tested was he tested for
coronavirus before the debate and trump
just
obviously lying and being dishonest and
trump lost it on savannah guthrie saying
she was terrible horrible all this stuff
same thing happened with 60 minutes
after about 45 minutes of the 60 minutes
interview
trump gets up and leaves and just
doesn't come back but he was
highly highly triggered first trump
tweeted a video
of the interviewer leslie stahl not
wearing a mask at the white house as an
attack on her
we later learned that this was just
moments after trump abruptly
left the interview and leslie stahl of
course being on camera had removed her
mask
and she was talking to producers about
like it's trump coming back or
is this over she hadn't yet put her mask
on trump attacking her for that that's
already weird
but then trump bizarrely tweeting about
the interview itself that quote
i am pleased to inform you that for the
sake of accuracy in reporting
i am considering posting my interview
with leslie stahl of 60 minutes prior to
air
time this will be done so that everybody
can get a glimpse of what a fake and
biased interview is all about
everyone should compare this terrible
electoral intrusion
with the recent interviews of sleepy joe
biden so i guess the
implication is maybe trump has
the raw video of the entire interview or
maybe trump's just lying who the hell
knows
but apparently a reporter asking real
questions
is considered an intrusion on the
electoral process now
per donald trump this is a joke guys we
are a joke the country is a joke this
man is a joke it really can't continue
and in normal situations
a president being unable to handle a 60
minutes interview
walking out it would be a national
scandal if barack obama had done this
uh it would be 24 7 on right wing news
saying
the president can't handle it what an
embarrassment he can't stand the heat
if he can't stand up to leslie stahl how
can he stand up to she and putin and kim
jong right
all that stuff if it had been obama with
trump
trump has so weaponized his followers
against the media
in a dystopian act of hostility that the
trumpists are furious if you look
at the places online where the trump is
hanging out the trumpists are furious
with leslie stahl and with 60 minutes
but what we can be sure of
is that if trump walked out the
interview must have been really bad
because even interviews that you and i
recognize as having gone badly for
donald trump trump thinks he did well
so if even trump thinks he didn't do
well in the interview
it must be a complete disaster if trump
flees the interview
and starts slamming the interviewer on
twitter
you know it went really really bad and i
hope that this is released
a sunday very much looking forward to it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here is one of our favorite callers from
west texas
uh take a listen to what he had to say
yes uh david this is a guy from west
texas again
uh i see our president's doing the same
thing he did with ukraine
uh do me a favor though so now he's
telling those voters
i'm not going to pass any stimulus bill
unless you vote for me and after you
vote for me and i get elected
i'll give you some money right it's the
same damn crap
okay yeah that's that's exactly right
and we talked about that last week trump
saying
if you elect me i will do a middle-class
tax cut well hold on
i thought you already did it but if you
didn't why didn't you and if you did why
are you promising the same thing again
uh trump with the payroll tax cut i will
defer it
until my second term and then make it a
permanent deferral if you re-elect me
it's trump saying i need you to do me a
favor you are absolutely right
and there are more examples of it that
we've covered um
and certainly i am sure more more that
will come up
on the bonus show today the battle over
that second coronavirus stimulus bill
is getting completely outrageous with
the points of view
from democrats pelosi
trump mcconnell the republican senate at
large
we're going to discuss it on today's
bonus show we will also talk about the
supreme court decision allowing a
three-day extension for pennsylvania
mail-in ballots
that is a decision that could determine
the election
most likely it won't but if we were to
say which one state could swing the
election
pennsylvania would be on the list and
we're going to talk about it and then
lastly
a majority now say the senate should
confirm
amy coney barrett to the supreme court
what happened what changed
we will discuss all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show how do you
get the bonus show it's very easy
you go to joinpakman.com and you sign up
coupon code is available
if you want a discount don't feel
obligated
it's available to anybody who wants it
you can use the coupon code
2020 now all one word all lowercase and
that will save you
66 percent off of the cost of a
membership i will see you on the bonus
show
otherwise tomorrow and remember tomorrow
night
starting about a half hour before the
presidential debate
about 8 30 p.m eastern time we will be
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor
is blinkist the app that lets you read
or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video